musical but George is what they're
shredding deloney shredding Courtney and
Eddie are up there singing along with
the band I mean these are talented
people I know but anyway and while we
were having a rock show we also had a uh
a smart conference where we all spoken
into every area of your life it's the
biggest and best event we do here at
Ramsey it's an all-day jam-packed event
covers every area of your life career
money mental health relationships
everything is there and we're going to
do our very first smart conference ever
here in Nashville we announced it
yesterday and we're gonna do something
different we're gonna do an entire
weekend
Friday night and all day Saturday and
this is going to be the first event we
host at our brand new Ramsay Event
Center
so you'll be the inauguration event
you're going to get commemorative
tickets oh you know I've got the
commemorative tickets for the from the
first Nashville Predators game oh yeah
sure Daniel Ramsey was a little guy many
years ago we went to that together and
I've actually got the pucks that they
handed out there commemorative that
night someday they'll be worth nothing
they still are but uh but if they're a
nice thing to a nice moment memory a
nice momento no promises that these
commemorative tickets will ever have a
future value but they're going to be
very cool and you will have participated
in something very unique uh we're gonna
have music uh some fun prizes this is
Music City so you just don't know which
one of my friends might show up
particularly Friday night you never know
I'm very excited about Friday night I I
don't know I haven't even I I haven't
even asked yet so we'll just see and
right you know make it I may get a
handful of those you never know we'll
see but uh uh we'll see anyway uh smart
conference has all the Ramsay
personalities me Ken Coleman Rachel Cruz
George Campbell Dr John deloney
Christina Ellis here's the thing we have
very very limited tickets these things
are usually six to eight thousand people
the one with six thousand people the
other day in Dallas
they're always sold out and the new
event center holds 2400.
they went on sale yesterday uh oh
so if you want to come April 14th and
15th a Friday night and a Saturday make
a Nashville weekend of a smart
conference be there for the inaugural
event at the Ramsey Event Center tickets
start as low as 79 they're going very
fast we have VIP we have a super VIP
thing that is got unbelievable benefits
look at all of it on the website you do
want to get these tickets and if you're
going to get one of the higher end
tickets they go first usually the VIP
the super VIP platinums all that kind of
stuff be sure and look for those but the
general admission and everything will be
gone very quickly because it's a
basically about a fourth the size we
usually do and it's a very special event
with this being the inaugural events I I
gotta say this is not something that
we've prepared I want to tell the
audience that this new event center we
get to look at it every day when you
drive in it's like a shining City on the
hill it overlooks our main campus and
this is going to be a special special
Gathering April 14 15. that's a
wonderful time of year in Nashville it
is spring has spring it's a good
temperature you're not smothered in the
humidity I'm not freezing to death you
get to come make a whole week a week
week and a half weekend out of it
whatever Hot Chicken in Nashville
country music Ramsey Solutions like man
come in on Friday watch the show we'll
be on the show great we'll be doing the
show here because the event won't start
until after the show on Friday afternoon
and I've got to mention uh Dr Donald Dr
John Delaney I'll probably make sure
that he's he's recording that day I'll
record let's just have a big full day
out of it love on everybody have fun I
mean it's it's a great environment and I
can't wait I got very excited when I saw
the email it's a good it's a good it's a
good program so all of this at
ramsesolutions.com events just find
Smart conference Friday and Saturday
April 14 and 15 get your tickets while
you can Mike is in Madison Wisconsin hey
Mike welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave and Ken appreciate you taking my
call sure what's up
yeah
um so I have been listening for about
two years uh first time caller though
and uh the reason I'm calling is that uh
currently I am on baby step four five
and six
um I'm an engineer and I heard you
talking about that before so I really
think about the numbers and as far as uh
you know becoming everyday millionaire
and whatnot
um my wife and I have one three and a
half year old son right now and we
currently pay 305 a week for daycare so
that's a pretty big bite on the budget
we have no other debt besides uh the
house the mortgage and it's no student
loans no credit card debts or anything
of that sort doing great uh we are yeah
thank you uh we are floating the idea of
another child but when I do my budgets
we are about twelve hundred dollars
Surplus every month for a normal month
uh that doesn't include if you know car
news tires or a fill washing machine you
know clunks out or whatever it may be so
an infant uh daycare is going to be more
than 300 a week like my three and a half
year old is now because he is potty
trained so I'm like struggling with the
idea of cutting my Surplus each month
down to zero or even negative
1200 to add a newborn to daycare
it sure as heck goes I pay 305 a week
right now for three and a half year old
and you're gonna it's gonna be 1500 now
a month
uh it would be I would say it'd probably
be you know somewhere around 1300 a
month for a newborn
or a three-month-old anyway after the
journey leaves okay all right then
you're gonna have to look for um other
because you're you're now at uh you're
now paying the daycare more than you
guys make
um
that's what you're telling me
uh no 1200 a month Surplus
yeah after after those are paid uh we
might not counted a new baby going to
daycare
when we're not yeah we're not pregnant
or anything we're all floating the idea
of it and you know right now we're at
1200 Surplus but if we were to have a
baby you know say 10 months from now uh
and put the baby in daycare you know
it's daycare then we would be negative
so you and I are spending all this time
worrying about a hypothetical
correct okay now we're not gonna worry
about hypotheticals dude
[Laughter]
I mean it's wise to plan but you're over
analyzing and everything just calm down
you're going to be making more money
you're going to have to find a different
daycare if you literally have no money
left after paying daycare then that
means you've got too expensive a daycare
you got to do something different and
you're going to try to find a different
situation when and if you have a second
child but I don't think we need to worry
about this today that's right and I I
will just I'll just add practically uh
when When Stacy and I uh when our three
kids were younger we looked at daycare
and in the area where we lived in North
Georgia it was really really expensive
and we ran up against this thing and to
what Dave said can be done and I'll just
point out that we said well daycare is
not an option so you know we did we
started talking to everybody we knew hey
does anybody know a Grandmama who wants
to work a little bit wants to make a
little extra spending cash you trust her
she's got grandbabies she's retired and
we found the right people and so we
found daycare in the form of an awesome
Christian grandmother who came in and
took care of the kids while Stacy and I
worked and it was a fraction she was
thrilled we were thrilled where there's
a will there's a way and you don't have
to just rely on what has become an
enormous expense it is admittedly very
large expansion yeah yeah and so but uh
I also don't spend I'm not going to burn
a whole lot of calories on stuff that
might happen something that's correct so
we're going to work about you know when
God says to have babies have babies the
best thing you can do on the planet is
babies babies are awesome
the only thing better than babies are
grand babies
and so um if I'd known how great
grandbabies are going to be I'd have
been nicer to their parents yeah you get
all the fun stuff and then you get to
send them home well I had Daniel's last
night and he was he was kind of having a
hard time about about uh you know uh
bedtime or whatever right and I actually
had this shirt on and I went to come out
here and I looked down there's baby snot
all over the side of the shirt I had to
wipe it all off before I got out here a
while ago I had to get the had to get
the damp cloth out and get the Eli snot
off there it is there we go hazards of
being Papa Dave That's it man but um you
know and I can tell you this we didn't
charge them near enough for keeping I
bet you did
they got a deal
yeah you're gonna figure it out as you
go my man and you're a good man for
thinking about it you're a good dad for
planning ahead but don't plan so far
ahead that you live and worry
that's not what we're going to do with
that good question thanks for the call
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author host of the Ken
Coleman show is my co-host today in the
lobby of Ramsey Solutions Jennifer and
Travis are with us hey guys how are you
Dave better than we deserve I love it
brother how much of y'all paid off uh
425 000 in 12 years but we got gazelle
intense in 30 months we paid off 280
thousand dollars whoa okay and your
range of income in that 30 months yeah
30 months 154 000 to 220. cool and where
do y'all live Denver Colorado cool what
do you do for a living I'm a restaurant
consultant and I'm a registered nurse in
leadership
okay and so you can work all you want to
work for sure
[Laughter]
oh for sure oh my goodness wow so what
kind of debt was the 425 thousand
well we paid off our house which was the
280 000. oh look at that weird people
and then before that it was student
loans two cars we had solar panels
credit cards
we were just kind of normal yeah kind of
normal okay so tell me your story what
woke you up and then what got you so
intense 30 months ago
so what woke us up 30 months ago is we
finally got to baby step six oh okay uh
we became gazelle intense at that point
a little backwards but uh we really
wanted to pay our house out by the time
we hit 40. okay
um and so we you know looked what does
that look like what do we need to do to
get there and we became pretty gazelle
intense that's so weird I paid for a
house by the time you're 40. yes none of
your friends do no right yeah so what
was what caused that goal to happen what
made you do that we just wanted to be
weird we wanted to be debt free we
wanted to leave a legacy and just see
what God will do in our lives and you
know we wanted to give to the kingdom on
a bigger level amen wow so when you
decide in baby step six so you've been
walking the steps and then you get
gazelle yeah so I'm really curious I
want you to unpack that for our
listeners and viewers what did that look
like what were the habits that changed
the lifestyle changes to do what you
just pulled off
yeah so first it started with um you
know creating a budget then then it
became living very minimally and
deciding what is it we really need and
um Travis learned to fix everything
around the house and cars just off of
YouTube and we didn't eat out we ate
dinners at home and had fun with the
kids at home with games and
um did you get into this at all at baby
step six and then go wait a second we
this is crazy we're living like what's
going on why are we doing this or did
you just have maniacal Focus the whole
time you know it really seemed like it
took forever to get past baby step three
right and then once we got past that and
got retirement set up College set up
it's like wow we're almost there at the
Finish Line let's get this done yeah
well yeah so seeing the Finish Line
turns you loose really that's pretty
interesting yeah it just so what's the
house worth
um so eight hundred thousand wow how
much is in your retirement accounts I a
little over I think 150 000. okay so
you're at baby steps millionaire status
then are really close yes really close
way to go guys congratulations yes so
proud of y'all thank you feel to be
completely free and 40. serious it feels
yeah awesome surreal it's crazy to be
here that the journey is finally
finished maybe step six wow that part of
the journey is yeah you still gotta go
right go ahead and become wealthy and go
ahead and be outrageously generous like
you said giving to the kingdom yes put
you in a position to do that you're
making serious money and uh not a
payment in the world right what's your
first big Financial thing you're going
to do now that you're 40 with no house
payment no payment of any kind well now
we're starting to redo our house
um so we've really held off on that as
well
um so now we're kind of remodeling
upgrading the house what are you doing
to it
everything painting kitchen upgrades
kitchen yeah okay so the question is
Travis are you doing it are you gonna
pay somebody now I'm still doing it yeah
we're still doing it I'm very jealous I
have to confess that you can watch
YouTube and do something productive at
home I'm worthless to Stacy it's it's
unfortunate you are definitely he's done
some crazy things
so that's incredible good for you yeah
wow what are you what do you tell people
the key to getting out of debt is
so really it's living like no one else
today
um you've got to create a budget you've
got to get a control over your money
and just really believe in yourself in
the process and you know keep coming
back even if you get derailed because
life's gonna happen
and cross the finish line you'll do it
eventually
hmm what caught you off guard about this
process
what was the surprise in the whole thing
I actually with my job I actually got
furloughed so being able to look and say
we had the money set aside to be able to
support ourselves through that process
but we actually were leveling so
minimally that we actually didn't have
to dive into that money at all yeah
which is like that eye opener like we're
doing something right when we can just
say we're living at the right level to
be able to keep driving you know and
then they brought you all back yeah that
was and pandemic stuff I guess right
yeah that was that was but we were
prepared shared yeah covet hit we
already had baby step three we were
living minimally to pay off the house so
it didn't have a devastating effect on
us financially thankfully
um Dave I want to ask a question I
haven't asked in debt free screamers on
this uh and I don't want to minimize the
effects of inflation I don't want to in
any way be insensitive to the fact that
that goods and services cost more but
knowing what you all know how does
inflation when you hear things of
inflation you actually see the cost how
does it affect someone like you guys
so it doesn't affect us as much as
somebody else who is you know living
paycheck to paycheck because we do have
that extra cushion uh to get us through
that yeah yeah cool good for you guys I
love it well done well done well we've
got a copy of The Total Money Makeover
for you in the live and give bundle and
that'll give you something to give away
and encourage somebody else on this
journey uh the baby steps millionaire
book our latest number one best seller
and uh that's the next chapter in your
story you're there almost be there you
may get there by the time you get home
you never know and uh Financial Peace
University membership for a year if you
haven't been through it go through it
it's got all the new videos in it or
give it away and again encourage someone
else on their Journey all right let's
bring the kiddos up and tell us their
names and ages all right we've got Blake
he's nine and then Ava she is seven oh
cute very good very good well done guys
very proud of y'all your rock stars well
done good stuff Jennifer Travis Blake
and Ava from Colorado 425
000 paid off house and everything 12
years but most of it done in the last 30
months making 154 to 220. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream
three two one we're different
hey
wow
[Applause]
yeah
yeah this is how it's done right here
you have to decide something different
has to happen otherwise you're going to
be just like everyone else out there
you know it's amazing in America how
many people are just alike
got the same car payments still got
Sallie Mae in the spare bedroom she's
hanging out still after 15 or 12 years
never going to get the house paid off
always going to have a mortgage just
trying to figure out a way to get by and
have some kind of joy for the weekend
yeah and that's most people don't be
normal no these people I'm talking to
right here they're weird that's right
they paid a price to win they said it
they took a moment and said I've had it
I'm not living like this anymore
it changes everything it really does
when you see the smiles and the weight
lifted and you see two little ones who
have an unbelievable uncapped future
because of the discipline that their mom
and Dad decided to exhibit and they're
going to learn from this later on
they've already seen it they've seen it
modeled and this is what it's about I
love that you said they paid the price
you know everybody else is miserable
everybody else is unhappy looking for
something trying to make it to the
weekend to drink their face off on
Friday night and financial peace and
peace Beyond Financial Peace is waiting
for you if you're just willing to do the
work that's what it takes this is the
Ramsay shop
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
Coleman and our product team our
developer team
got together a couple of years ago and
spent a bazillion hours and a lot of my
money uh developing this assessment that
is absolutely Lights Out it's called the
get clear assessment we launched the
assessment when we launched your latest
book from paycheck to purpose and uh
literally tens of thousands of people
have taken the assessment now to uh to
find out about your talent your passion
your mission and to be able to aim at
something with your career talk about
why you developed this for a second and
what it is Ken well you know the reason
I developed is because many years ago I
went through my own kind of career
crisis I was heading down One path had
been heading that direction for a while
and making progress and I had a change
of heart and it really shook me because
I went to a place of confusion as I'd
been going One Direction and I knew I
wasn't going to go that direction
anymore but what direction should I go
and that's a very intimidating thing for
people because you're thinking about
your livelihood taking care of Stacy and
the three kiddos uh you're worried about
what other people are going to say uh
because that's just who we are as humans
and so you put all that together and I
was at a place of real confusion and
then that confusion turned to
frustration and a bit of hopelessness
and as I went through life mapping and
processing it on my own with some great
men around me who had some experience
um I when I came to Ramsey Solutions I
wanted to put together a methodology
that anybody could understand to be able
to answer the question how do I discover
what I'm supposed to do with my life
what should I do with my life it's why
kids go to college every parent wants
their kid to be able to be successful
and it's a very intimidating question
and not a lot of succinct answers so as
you know for years before we started
this I I felt like it was very simple to
answer the question and this is the
sentence that I've developed that
anybody can understand if you use what
you do best to do work you love to
produce results that matter to you
you're on purpose it's that simple in
fact
that's how you know if it's a dream job
because if you use what you do best and
you're doing something you love and
you're producing results that matter
guess what you look forward to going in
to the day you're going to have a lot of
energy you're operating under tremendous
efficiency and you see tremendous
meaning in the contribution that your
work makes so Talent Plus passion plus
Mission equals purpose and here's the
even better part really nice pay
because Pete you're going to stand out
people are going to go they'll say
things like you were born for this or
you're a natural and so this speaks to
what you and I believe in our entire
organization that we were created to
work
to do good works and so those are the
three elements so then I said we need to
have a tool to where a person who's not
listening to the Ramsey show the Ken
Coleman show or coming to the smart
conference could be self-assessed and
get those elements very clear and then
have a purpose statement to where they
could see at a high level this
is what I was created to do and then
have the freedom to look in the
marketplace and see well I could go here
I could do this I could do this all of
which allow me to be uniquely me and so
that was the impetus behind the tool so
from the CEO seat of course I approved
the process that you all went through to
do this and saw the updates on the
product as it was being developed and I
was just getting by I keep my eyes on a
few things and that was one of them that
was happening didn't think anything more
about it and then I get an email from
you the other day hey take the
assessment yeah and I'm like dude I kind
of know what I'm supposed to do don't
take the assessment right no I know what
I'm supposed to do he goes no I want to
see if it works on you yeah and I
thought well let's see if the stupid
thing works and so I took it and the
stupid thing works yeah it nailed it
yeah so uh can I read your do you want
to read it all right so so I told you
all you get the three elements Talent
passion Mission now here's what the
report does you get a detailed report
yeah one page that says here are your
top three here are your mid-range
talents and then here's the stuff quite
frankly you suck at and and it's okay
because because you're not supposed to
focus much on that and so we do that
with passion stuff that Dave loves so
talents what he's good at passion what
Dave loves to do and then mission is
what motivates Dave what motivates Dave
to come in and so here is his statement
I was created to use my talents of
persuasion instruction and communication
to perform my passions of leading
promoting and Performing to accomplish
my mission of influence by producing
change in progress now that doesn't
sound like Dave Ramsey I don't know what
does and and so what this does not for
Dave but for anybody who's a little bit
confused maybe lacking some confidence
it gives them a chance to see themselves
as the world sees them how they are
uniquely put together and that purpose
statement is a high level job
description for a couple reasons number
one for the person who's maybe a college
student or someone who's just been
wandering they can now begin to have a
North star a compass and then for
someone who's in it and starting to
wonder should I stay with it because I'm
going through a valley which happens
then what it does for them is gives them
tremendous confidence and courage to
stay and so that's what this tool does
clarity and confidence I think I'm a
simpleton every time I take one of these
things of any kind it completely Nails
me well I mean 40 years ago I took the
disc the disc and I came out 98 D 98 I
and I came on my handed it to my wife we
had never seen anything like these kinds
of Assessments back in those days you
know hand it to her we were sitting
there talking and she's reading it
she's like yep yep yep this is what's
wrong with you I went what's wrong with
me that is me now what's wrong with me
and then she took it and she is
determined as an sc that that's the
proper thing to be and all the rest of
us are wrong well
for 30 years that's not how this works
but all right right uh and then it took
the Enneagram our friend Ian cron right
oh sure and uh he like I wrote eight for
you oh yeah it's like you are the
quintessential Enneagram eight exactly
when you see a freaking autobiography
right the pictures next to it yeah and
this thing here man it got it hit it I
mean persuasion instruction
communication to lead to promote to
perform to have influence and that's
what we do here I mean that's a lot what
a lot of Ramsay does for that matter
because it comes out of the you know out
of the DNA of the leader and the founder
that's exactly right and so um yeah this
thing is it's the get clear assessment
folks
and uh how much is it you ready for this
it's only ten dollars until the end of
October so you only have a few days left
for the whole month of October we've
reduced it from thirty dollars to ten
dollars and here's what's great about it
it's digital now you can do a printout
like we did here but you're also going
to get a PDF it'll send you the download
on your own 30 page report that really
goes deep and it's very impressive I
mean when you read through it I'm just
like yep yeah yeah wonderful gift by the
way you know you've got a college kid
coming out of college trying to figure
out what to do you got to well or
somebody just kind of struggling you've
got friends that are in the in between
spot yeah it's like I don't know man I
thought I knew this and I don't know
anything and there's something
um
it kind of when you don't know where you
are like that it dashes your confidence
yes sure it does and you don't you don't
have the uh I don't know the energy to
move forward on stuff when you're not
sure when you're unsure here's how I
talk about it if you've ever driven in a
downpour of rain and it comes on you
quickly a deluge or tremendous fog you
immediately pull the car over you slow
down first tremendously you slow down
and you pull over why you can't see past
the hood of the car this is the same way
in our work in our career and purpose
that if we're not quite sure we're not
clear on where we're going and why we're
going what do we do we pull back and
it's the paralysis by analysis and a
tool like this uncovers who you are get
the results run them by somebody who
knows you really well get some feedback
and it'll give you that added confidence
to be uh who you were created to be well
and I'm convinced that the um the
algorithm that we put together to do
this is unbelievably accurate so yeah it
is I mean it certainly nailed me no
questions very smart people that can do
all this yeah
this gyration and you spent a lot of
time in the wordsmithing because you
knew what you wanted it to say and how
you wanted it to feel so uh check it out
the get clear assessment usually thirty
dollars at ramseysolutions.com through
the end of the month uh that will be up
until Halloween Monday right you can uh
you can get it and uh it's only ten
dollars that's like the deal of the
century for ten dollars it's just like a
novelty yeah I was very upset at uh Dave
when he said that I said Dave I can't
feed my kids he said shut up Coleman
we're giving it away for ten dollars oh
none of that actually happened but what
we wanted to do is we wanted to make it
uh an accessible tool for people to try
it and it's really about self-awareness
if you break it down this is a tool
that'll give you self-awareness you know
you gotta which is a superpower a small
team of five or something you just buy
them all one easy what I would do you
know that's exactly right and then you
could have a great discussion with that
or the if you've got you know you want
to have a fun discussion over
Thanksgiving with the family yeah have
all the grown kids take it yep and
that'll make Thanksgiving dinner
interesting yeah yeah there we go hey
it's better than talking politics talk
purpose most anything's better that's
right
that puts this hour of the Ramsey Show
in the books
foreign
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show we're dead as Dom cash is
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships this is a
show about you and your life Ken Coleman
Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author host of the Ken
Coleman show is my co-host today Cindy
starts this hour in Dallas Texas hey
Cindy how are you
I'm just fine thank you
um my situation is I am 61 years old I'm
in a job I've been with this company for
12 years I want to change jobs
um if I
I need to work with people that care
about their job that come to their work
and do the work and know what they're
expected to do and do it
um my Instagram that you talked about
I'm a moral perfectionist loyal guardian
and I also did Ken Commons
assessment I'm my talent is inspection
instruction execution my passion is
leading finishing analyzing and my
mission is achievement I want to change
job but my friends and family are
telling me I should not because of my
age I need to stay put because it's
going to be hard for me to find a job
and I have applied for jobs and I don't
even get an interview now when I used to
get lots of interviews I mean I have
Stellar work history and
I just been stuck I sure know what to do
okay so before we get into uh the
applying process and what frustrating
results you're dealing with there I'm
just curious I heard some things on you
that I've heard before and I'm just
curious what you would say is the number
one and maybe two reasons why you want
to leave this company
give me the quick version
okay
um because
the people they're
um I mean they don't come to work and
it's an office it's a professional sure
business
um I mean they they call in I mean they
don't want to work I mean they sleep at
their desk all right let me ask you this
I'm a worker I know I can tell are you
leading those people or are these
co-workers well they were co-workers but
our manager left they moved me into the
management position and I asked to be
moved back because I I just couldn't I
mean I want people to know what their
job is do their job be able to do their
job be capable of doing it and do your
job I get it now let's just go back and
I'm not in management anymore got it
okay now let's remove that frustration
from our conversation just for a moment
let's just put it over to the side
do you love what you're doing do you
like what you're doing forget the
frustration my work and I love our
clients so a couple of things I want you
to consider I'm not in any way telling
you not to look elsewhere however
your Enneagram that you shared with us
is really at the source your wiring is
at the source of your frustration that
moralist and what's happening I know I
know and I get it and I want to try to
set you free from it because you had the
opportunity to do something about it
when you were in management but you
walked away from them not getting on you
about it not judging you but you you had
as a manager theoretically if you had
supportive support above you to Fire and
get rid of some of those people or to
Mentor them and and see what motivates
them you had your chance there but now
that you're back if you want to stay
where you are because you love the work
and you're 61 and you're having a hard
time looking out you know and seeing
other opportunities you've got to get to
the point where you go I'm responsible
for my work and I am their co-worker not
their mom I am their co-worker not their
aunt I am their co-worker not their
leader and you've got to decide because
what I'm hearing from here judge jury
and execution that's right it's not your
call and so the source of all of your
tension and frustration is you looking
at everybody else sloughing off slacking
I get it
I get it I get the frustration it
affects it affects my work only okay all
right that was my next question how much
is it affecting your ability to do your
job now this is the question not how
much is it affecting your ability to
focus on your job because I think you're
focused on them and giving them too much
power
but how much is it affecting your
ability see that's what the giggle is
how much is it affecting your ability to
actually execute on your work
five percent ten percent
um
maybe 10. I I don't know it's just when
there's errors made I'm the one that has
to deal with our customers
okay have you taken this to your leader
to say hey I'm crushing it but I'm
having to deal with it they're afraid
they don't want to lose anybody because
we've already had a lot a lot of leave
and that's what's going on right now we
have a lot of leaders right now that are
afraid to fire anybody because of this
big gap we have those aren't leaders
those are wusses that's exactly right
you can't control that so what you have
to decide here is wait a second what is
best for me Cindy
because if I love my work can I at the
age of 61 with a lot of maturity and a
lot of work ethic can I allow this stuff
to bounce off of me or is it no longer
tenable I can't do this any longer
that's what I really want to know I
think you go get a new job I think so
too but I also don't fly so walk her
through walk her through the application
process well I wanted to challenge you
because I don't think it's as bad as
you're making it out to be but here's
the thing if you got to get noticed in
today's world it's not by applying
online because even small businesses are
using softwares and and they're weeding
people out you're 61 which means you
have at least four Decades of
relationships and connections and you
have got to shake the tree you got to
get out there and go hey I'm looking to
move on here's specifically what I'm
looking for and it is relationships that
will get you in the door because they go
let me tell you about Cindy Cindy's
amazing but if you just apply and some
people may see your age they may not but
you may not even get your resume looked
at so this is all about the proximity
principle I wrote about book that
details this in great detail I'll give
it to you we'll put you we'll give it to
you when we put you on hold but this is
about you leveraging your relationship
Capital do you understand what I'm
saying yeah yeah I think you have a
distinct Marketplace Advantage because
you actually know how to work and you're
mature no question you actually know how
to work yeah I mean we got a whole group
of people out there that honestly
somebody just needs to shut their butt
on fire
I mean really seriously I just freaking
lazy quiet quitting will get you nothing
I'm telling you man if you NE if you aim
at mediocrity and you think uh playing
Call of Duty four hours a day while you
call it while you're supposed to be
doing work from home is a good idea
you're you're going to be nothing in
your life and you're going to deserve
every bit of that yeah so you know we if
you have the ability to to light
yourself on fire to get up leave the
cave kill something drag it home you
want to be somebody you want to be great
you want some greatness in your life you
want to throw your shoulders back and
Howl at the Moon and cause some stuff to
happen like Cindy does you are an
absolute rock star in America today
that's right I mean if you actually what
she's saying is the bar is so freaking
low if you show up at work and work
while you're at work you stand out
I mean that's how easy it is out there
right now in the land of stupid
just show up at work and work while
you're at work
aim at some greatness be somebody Cindy
I think you need to get a new job I
think you work with doofuses
hold on we're going to send you a copy
of uh Ken's new Ken's book proximity
principle so you can find some good
people to work with
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I say it all the time if you're a
business owner and you don't know your
numbers you don't know your business and
when markets are shifting it's even more
important you've got to know where you
stand so you make your next move the
right move and you don't have to be in
the dark here over 31 000 businesses
including my team at Ramsey know their
numbers because they use netsuite by
Oracle the number one Cloud Financial
system netsuite gives you visibility and
control of your financials planning
budgeting and inventory so you can
manage risk get reliable forecasts and
improve margins having everything in one
place has saved my team hours each week
since we made the switch to netsuite
netsuite is a game changer so head on
over to netsuite.com Ramsey to get a
product tour today that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today it's launch week for our brand new
gazelle debit card this is the debit
card will help you spend and save the
Ramsay way the gazelle debit card works
the same as your standard debit card
with the same FDIC protections the same
fraud protection from MasterCard is
backed up by an FDIC Bank it is made for
you which means we will not feed you to
death some of these cards have more fees
on them than a French poodle Fifi Fifi
Fifi and check it out this doesn't so we
won't sell your personal information we
won't try to get debt push on pushed on
you we won't run a commercial with sweet
little people and then try to run you
into 22 percent debt like Sofi we
actually are just gonna have a debit
card that works and stuff wow go to
ramseysolutions.com tens of thousands of
people have already gotten their gazelle
card we just launched it Monday it's
yeah crazy I love it I'm so proud of our
team and by the way it is the coolest
looking debit card I was gonna say
something so here's all the things that
Dave just said as a reason why you
should get it I'm going to add one more
it makes you look cool when you use it
well I'm gonna go A step above that you
get a chance to talk about financial
peace and Ramsey the Ramsay way and how
you've changed your life I'll tell you
why it looks so stinking cool to your
point that when you flash that out you
know and you in the grocery line two or
three people behind you I'm telling you
people will say hey what is that I think
it really is an ambassador card as well
I would throw that on top of all the
other reasons because I've never seen a
debit card look anywhere close to that
cool I mean that gazelle on there is
he's a he's a if we were ever going to
have a sports team that would be our
mascot who if which we're not the mascot
for Financial Peace University it's for
the gazelles
that would be our softball team name
yeah it's really cool it's our football
team we're the gazelles yeah uh
ramsaysolutions.com gazelle and you can
get started today Hannah is with us in
Detroit hey Hannah what's up
hey Dave how are you I can't believe I
got on the air I'm so excited well we're
honored to have you how can we help
I can articulate my thoughts well by
um so my situation
um is that my husband and I are
expecting our first baby in about four
weeks
we I I'm the one that really runs the
finances he's the one who makes the
majority of our income I work really
hard every year to try to keep us out of
debt but once the holidays roll around I
feel like we're always starting our year
with some Consumer Debt and so through
this year I've been setting some money
aside out of his paycheck every month to
hopefully pad our savings for when the
baby's coming and kind of pay for like
baby stuff throughout the year as well
as trying to tackle our credit card debt
and really kind of like super fund our
savings account well now I'm at a place
where
I'm just feeling really stressed out
about how to tackle baby step number two
if I should pause that step
um you know since we have our baby and
just uh stockpile cash I'm just feeling
a little bit confused on what the next
step is is this your first baby
how old are you
I am 30 and my husband is 33. cool
what's your household income
our household income is about 56 000
okay you're trying to do seven things at
once nesting getting ready for a baby
and none of them are working and you're
frustrated
which makes you like a normal human
yeah just stop it just stop it just
breathe I think you have one you have
job one baby
have a baby that's your only job right
now
just calm down
don't do nothing else but have a baby
that's all I want you to do
you think you're not in charge of the
world you don't have to balance the
national debt just have a baby
just enjoy now what we tell you to do as
far as the baby steps go during this
time is stop everything and just pile up
cash
I want to see how big a pile of cash you
can have before baby comes
okay so don't touch it don't touch don't
complicate it
just stop doing everything
and pile up cash as high as you can pile
it and don't be blowing a bunch of money
you don't need to spend seven thousand
dollars on a human that weighs two
pounds or five pounds
they don't take up that much room yeah
off of Amazon
okay just breathe and pile up money and
have a baby and then when baby gets home
and you got a big old pile of money then
you can start your baby steps and we'll
use that pile of money to go on the debt
and we'll begin to plow our way through
the dead okay
long do you think I should pause these
up to four then I want you to pause
everything until you and baby get home
from the hospital and everybody's
healthy how much money do you think as
big a pile as you can pile between now
and then
okay it's impossible for you to have too
big a pile of money between now and the
time you come home with baby safe now
when you come home with baby safe we're
gonna push play on the baby steps okay
and we're gonna take everything but a
thousand dollars and throw it at all
your Dad we're gonna work through that
snowball maybe step two and we're gonna
go boom boom boom boom boom boom and
we're game on then okay
and then we're gonna be focused and
we're gonna be intense but right now big
pile of money have a baby
sample all right even though I won't be
making any income for about three months
my husband will so should I still start
the stuff can you live on your husband's
income
yes
yeah yeah I can especially with the
savings that we have already no I didn't
say you're going to use the savings I
asked if you could live on the income
currently we do not live on Justice what
does he make he makes
he makes about
45 45 000 a year how much is your rent
um our mortgage is 8
8.8 how much are your car payments
uh just 250 a month for mine hasn't paid
you can live on your income his income
yeah okay great you're just gonna have
to just watch what you're doing and you
don't have to have the same you don't
have to live like you're living now but
you can live on his income until you're
back to work and then we take then once
your income's coming in again we will
advance quickly through the debt
snowball and through the other things
but um and this idea that he brings home
the bacon and you fry it is a bunch of
crap
okay his job is half of this equation is
to help make the decisions with the
money the two you need to make the
decisions together if you write the
checks that's fine you can be the
administrative CFO of the house but uh
you don't need to carry all the
responsibility by yourself he has the
responsibility of making the money and
then I have the responsibility of being
stressed out about the money uh no
that's not how this works we make
decisions together and he carries it
with you so hang on we're going to sign
you guys up for Financial Peace
University we want you to go through
that as well I just want to point out
Hannah very quickly that if your husband
is on board with this sounds like he is
and you still got a little bit of fear
even though Dave walked you through the
budget you guys can do it on his income
there's nothing keeping him from pulling
some weekends some nights right now
there's a there's a surplus of of
part-time jobs for someone who just
wants to make money for Christmas who
wants to get that emergency fund uh baby
step one filled right now is a wonderful
time and piling up cash could involve
your husband and maybe should involve
him taking on some extra work so that
you can just let the baby right just
take care of the baby in your body and
you just kind of chill he can go out and
bust it and pile up some more cash I
would be challenging him to think about
that
there you go
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five so when you are
facing a large
event that is that makes everything
unpredictable it's okay to push pause on
your baby steps pregnancy is a great
example of that a job loss is another
great example of that
um things like that then you push pause
and you get through the storm and then
you push play again and you go again
but um the the stress comes from I'm
trying to save money for the baby I'm
trying to save money for this I'm trying
to work the debt snowball I'm trying to
get ready for this I'm trying to do this
I'm trying you've got too many things on
your plate and people do that all the
time and the easiest thing to do is just
uh get the old uh get the old machete
out and take some stuff out of your life
and go not doing that
not doing that not doing that no is a
complete sentence and your anxiety level
goes down every time you say no
nope not doing that nope I'm so sorry I
love you and I can't come nope sorry
nope I think you're gonna be awesome but
I won't be there nope thanks you're
amazing no can't come stress goes down
every time you do it I do it all the
time this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
oh
foreign
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you
that's why you need to get in touch with
Churchill Mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for you that means
they check in every year with free
consultations to help you stay on the
right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsey trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality host of the
Ken Coleman show is my co-host today in
the lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the
debt-free stay age Colin is with us hey
Colin how are you I'm better than I
deserve Dave how about you just the same
sir I've heard that before very cool
where do you live I live in Amarillo
Texas oh fun welcome to Nashville and
how much debt have you paid off I paid
off 81
756 dollars in two and a half years way
to go and your range of income during
that two and a half years I started off
at 45 000 and I ended at a hundred two
thousand dollars okay wow very cool so
what do you do for a living I'm a
medical device sales rep oh you're doing
well yes how are you good job all right
and uh 82 000 was what kind of debt so
that was all student loans whoa yes sir
Sally May did have her own place with
you wow yes sir how long you been out of
school so I've been out of school for
three years okay so you get out of
school and you say gotta get rid of
Sallie Mae absolutely
um I just remember living in Dallas
um I was a former Collegiate athlete
graduated with my Master's Degree living
you you know just that young
professional perfect world
um just entering into that workplace and
I just remember sitting down after that
six months grace period and really you
know totaling up the amount and I just
have an oh crap kind of believe it oh
crap yeah oh crap moment oh my gosh wow
so then then what did you do when you
said I don't know what you know this is
crazy but what's your next step how did
you find us how did you get on the
Ramsay way so
um honestly I was just on YouTube one
day and you know I just found one of
your videos I it was somebody who paid
like a hundred thousand dollars off in
three years and I was like wow like if
they could do it then I could do it so
um that was like the biggest thing for
me is just so you started like January
of 20. yes sir in like three months
after you start you get the pandemic yes
sir what did that do to your plan so the
pandemic was honestly one of the best
things that happened to me because I
started working from home in Dallas and
um I basically started applying for the
dream company that I work for right now
and I switched jobs and that's when I
began doing
um this is when I began doing medical
device sales and you know it was just
something that I prayed on for a long
time I've always been passionate about
what I do and after football it's just I
felt I felt like I didn't have a purpose
and who'd you play ball for I played
ball for West Texas A M okay yes sir and
then uh just kept preying on it praying
on it I wanted a career that you know I
was passionate about and it and it led
me there after apply in there 56 times I
finally got the job there wow you know
what um I just was able to double my
income and once again like I wake up
every single day and I love my job I
love the people you're going to be good
at sales you don't get turned away
easily absolutely no doesn't even
register for you emotionally no sir no
no no and I'm I'm not having fun with
that I'm I'm telling you like you have a
an unbelievable will focus and I'm just
curious how much you're athletic because
I want people who are not athletes yes
sir to get what's going on here how did
that play into your ability to to not be
deterred uh as it related to getting the
job after 56 times yes sir and then also
just buckling down and paying off an
enormous amount of debt in a small
amount of time talk about that what did
you harness absolutely I mean I just
think there's so much benefits to being
an athlete
um I tell this to all of my college
buddies you know
um because after you're done with your
career I mean it does leave you feeling
empty and a lot of the times we're so
passionate about what we do it's so
important to find a career that fulfills
you in a different way and for me
um I found that with my work and uh it
just gave me the ability to never take
no for an answer like you said and just
always strive every single day to be
better and I'm in a career that you know
challenged me every single day and I
love to I love to work with the people
that I'm around when you see your sales
results as a scoreboard
absolutely I mean every single day
absolutely that's what it is and I'm
part of a great team a team of three
guys that
um one of them was a former Collegiate
athlete at my school as well so they're
stocking out this 82 was just yet
another goal to hit yeah absolutely
that's right yeah
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is when they say you
paid off her here you paid off 82 000 in
two and a half years I think the key to
getting out of debt is just
um just coming to realization that it's
not going to go away and at the end of
the day
um
to just be disciplined and you know you
want to break that family tree and you
want to you know you want to be
Financial uh financially free and you
want to live the life 15 20 years down
the line but you know I think the
biggest thing is like sacrifice now
um and a lot of the times when I tell
people my story the two words I love to
use is delay gratification
um I understood that I had a sacrifice
now for the life that I want to live 15
20 years down the line yeah and uh it's
just so difficult
um it's just not normal for people my
age to do that nowadays so
um I just really wanted to
grab the horn grab those horns and you
know just attack it by the way it's
never been normal for people of any age
there's not been a generation that had
this down yeah but but that everybody in
that generation did it right but uh wow
that's very powerful good for you man
well done well done how's it feel to be
free
it feels amazing
um I still remember I wrote my last
check it was 6 500 and I actually drove
home to El Paso to celebrate with my
family and hit that last uh click and
record it and everything like that and I
just
I kind of got teary-eyed when I did it
just uh yeah just because it was just
such a journey and there were so many
sacrifices I came with it I'm 26 years
old and 100 free way to go dude that's
the biggest win of your life that's why
you got emotional yeah I mean what what
was what was one of the most disciplined
things or maybe the hard things you did
to sacrifice as a young single guy
coming out of school hey what would you
what were you doing I mean the biggest
thing is like
um not being able to eat out
um you know not always being able to go
to social events and if I did you know I
would just kind of sit there and you
know I wouldn't eat I wouldn't drink and
uh just staying focused and uh also a
part of that too is um I had a second
job at one point and I think that was
one of the lower points of My Life
um but I understood that you know once
again like it was for a shirt short term
yeah oh way to go man what I'm proud of
you well done calling beautiful
beautiful story very cool yeah hey we've
got the live and give bundle for you
that's The Total Money Makeover book for
you to give to somebody and encourage
them like you have been yes uh the baby
steps millionaire book which you are on
your way to that one for sure and uh and
of course the Financial Peace University
membership for a year we'll give you all
of those and use them yourself give them
away whatever whatever you need to do
that live and give bundle so very very
well done Colin beautiful job sir I love
it I love it all right Colin from
Amarillo Texas 82
000 in two and a half years making 45 to
102. count it down 26 years old he's
free let's hear a debt-free scream three
two one I'm debt free yeah
oh
[Music]
it did not occur to Colin
that he didn't owe the money
and that someone else should pay off his
debt like Washington it did not occur to
him to sit and wait on
President Biden to pay off his debts it
did not occur to him because he is a
stud that's right he gets stuff done it
did not occur to him that anything
should be done except this is one more
goal in my life that needs to be knocked
down it's what occurred to him yeah and
so this is the difference and you know
the interesting thing about all of those
things those are not things that are um
external virtues they are things that
you can just decide you're going to have
today I'm going to be a man I'm going to
be a woman of purpose I'm going to be a
man I'm going to be a woman of dignity
I'm going to be a man I'm going to be a
woman that's not waiting on a government
handout to make my life good I'm going
to be a man a woman that takes Life by
the throat
set your butt on fire people go be
somebody line up for greatness don't sit
around and try to figure out a way to
quiet quit because if you work here I'll
quiet fire your butt this is
unbelievable man that's not true it'll
be pretty loud time to get it done don't
be another quiet about it nothing quiet
about it don't let the door hit you in
the butt that's pretty lazy I got stuff
to do there's too many people need help
for you sit around on your dadgum
assumptions we got stuff to do man this
is the Ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality is my co-host
today open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five our question
of the day comes from blinds.com
blinds.com's 100 satisfaction guarantee
means even if you mismeasure or you pick
the wrong color they'll remake your
blinds for free you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more use the promo code Ramsay to get
the best deal today's question comes
from Sala in Colorado how do I write a
resignation letter I want to keep it
professional but companies need to be
called out on their so they can do
better in the future I love when Dave
steps in with the sound effect you can
just uh fill that in with your
imagination
um okay so let's just stick to the first
part of the question how do I write a
resignation letter I want to keep it
professional well then keep it
professional
um you know the the resignation letter
to me is is less important than the way
you handle yourself when you go in and
talk to your leader and uh you know the
advice I give to callers on the Ken
Coleman show as well as the Ramsey show
is leave the way you would want to be
left put yourself in the other person's
shoes even if it's not a great
environment even if you you feel wronged
or whatever the reality is it never does
you any favors by burning the bridge or
blowing the bridge up which we're seeing
a lot of young people do on Tick Tock
for heaven's sakes just leave with class
it's going to follow you when you least
expect it if you don't so on the
resignation letter I don't have three
points and here's how to do it it's very
simple be professional and keep it short
and sweet and you can turn it in when
you look at your leader thank you for
the opportunity please accept my two
week notice that's it keep it simple
gratitude clarity
say like if if they cared what you
thought about them
they would have already asked you
they don't care yeah for whatever reason
because they're dumb or because you're
belligerent I don't know which right but
they don't care what you think
so you telling them to get their
blankety blank blank stuff in order is
gonna do zero good that's correct
because they don't care what you think
period that's right okay I I you know I
probably fall in that category well I
think most everyone if you're if I you
know I quit doing exit interviews now
our HR team does exit interviews because
they want to try to find out why you're
leaving I'm not leaving
I'll be here yeah so I don't you know I
see you I I love you but I'm gonna keep
going you're not yeah and that's pretty
well the end of it that's right and you
know I don't need you throwing grenades
back in here at me as you leave it does
it does nothing except Make Me Remember
You that way that's right and the
probability or the percentage chance of
you telling them what you think about
what they need to change oh I never
thought of that I'm so glad you told me
I'm so thankful it's never gonna happen
so just just just leave yeah leave well
keep it simple and you've stayed too
long
if you feel that way if you're willing
to say companies need to be called out
on their blank that is absolutely you've
stayed too long yeah you needed to you
need to either call them out on their
blank and stay and help fix their blank
um you know or you're part of the
problem now and you've become part of
the problem so yeah you do need to get
out of there just keep it brief sweet
and say see ya wouldn't want to be you
and move on you know and
um then you can smile later and when you
calm down and you're gonna go well they
probably weren't as stupid as I thought
they were and so on you know yeah you
know it always cracks me up Dave when
people want to take a parting shot at
somebody and if it's so bad that you
want to leave then why aren't you happy
you're leaving you should be bubbly you
should walk in and go hey I'm leaving
today you know it's like what are we
doing the problem is social media has
raised a whole generation of activists
and everybody thinks they're a freaking
activist right you're not an activist
you're just a former employee
there's a difference I mean seriously
that's just your category you're just a
former employee that's all you are and
nobody really gives a crap what you
think they really don't that's correct
you and the three people that sit around
drink coffee with you and whine about
stuff from four years ago you're the
only ones that care you know and that's
so some of you people do this stuff and
and uh we've had it happen to us here
we've had it happen you know I've Got
Friends that run companies and and
people that do stuff and you know
they've never erected a statue to a
Critic that's true just never been done
so except that one to Roger E Roger
Ebert but um anyway Cisco neighbor
remember that yeah oh sure actually has
a statue oh he does I thought you were
kidding no that's I actually said that
from stage one time there's a famous
saying uh like Mark 20 or somebody said
he's never been a statue that's correct
somebody sent me a of course they did a
picture of Robert Roger Ebert's statue
good for him yeah that's good well I
mean you got to have something to do in
your life open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Jessica
is in Fort Worth Texas hey Jessica how
are you
I am so good and I'm honored to talk to
both of you you too I was at the Smart
conference and you were both so
inspiring Ken you really spoke to me and
thank you so much for what you do thank
you God thank you how can we help all
right so I've got an MD which I think
stands for money dummy
um and
I could I Gotta Laugh
um we were doing pretty good my husband
and I we were working our way through
the baby steps made it to steps four
five and six and then a few months ago
we were looking to move into a different
home we bought a home that we thought
was going to be everything we wanted it
was a great neighborhood we knew we were
going to put some money into fixing it
up and we felt okay with that then here
comes the mistake and actually we bought
it for 5.97 it appraised for 6.55 so we
were like we're doing great and then we
realized that the things we wanted to do
to this house to make it into what we
wanted
it was going to cost way too much money
and it was a mistake it was it was a
mistake and we relisted the house for
what we paid for it knowing we were
going to take a loss we got no offers at
all we left it up for about almost two
months and then we pulled it and said
okay
new plan we're gonna have to fix this
thing up and either rent it out or sell
it we're in that position right now and
I had been thinking the right thing to
do is to rent it out but now I'm
thinking this we're in too deep and I
think I want to get rid of it I'm taking
some guidance on that you need to sell
it
it's not a rental it's a mistake there's
a difference
your uh guidelines for how much we could
buy we figured we could afford um easily
850 000 house
um this house is so far under budget
that between that house and the one we
currently live in which we owe 265 on
we're still way under that
um and so that was kind of the
motivation like well you know we could
still pay these those off in less than
five years maybe we should stick it out
and get it done and then have it
generate income but I want to sell it
for a hundred thousand under less than
what you
paid for it but I would sell it
okay I'm not suggesting you give it away
but I think you need look five years
from today you're not gonna be happy you
own this house
it's not what you bought not what I
would have bought as a it's not what you
bought it for it's gonna buy you bought
it it's not your plan it's a burden and
really every time you come around it it
reminds you of a mistake rather than a
than a positive thing
yes yeah I bought stuff that I had
payments on in the past and every time I
wrote a check for it it reminded me I
was stupid I didn't like that
I have enough reminders of that because
we we paid off 433 000 of mostly student
loan debt wow
I got enough reminders of that for a
lifetime well good for you you cleaned
up a lot of stuff and I don't think
there's any reason to panic here uh and
so I'm gonna put it on the market make
sure it's shiny and shiny as it can be
to get it sold and put it at a
reasonable price and expect with these
higher interest rates in the market
slowing down for it to take longer than
it would have taken a year ago or two
years ago for sure but just uh give give
yourself some patience breathe put on
the market and let's have the plan of
getting rid of it because you don't want
to still be owning it later no and I
want to encourage you Jessica we I had
dinner we had a VIP dinner uh Friday
Night Before Our smart conference last
Saturday and I got to sit with a couple
of our Ramsey trusted real estate stars
in the Fort Worth Dallas area and they
told me both of them they said the cut
the the housing market is still strong
the difference is you're going to have
to paint it you're gonna have to do some
things that we used to do you're not
gonna have 40 people lining up to take
it as is so do what you got to do you're
going to be able to sell this house and
you're going to be fine yeah just normal
process of selling yeah and make sure
it's shiny yeah it's in good shape it's
going to take a few more months priced
properly yeah it's going to take 90 to
120 days and just get with one of our
real estate elps and they'll help you do
every bit of that price you properly
stage it everything
so hey you're gonna be okay I've been
there myself I don't think you're nearly
as dumb as you're giving yourself credit
for I think you just made a mistake this
is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio it's the
Ramsay show where that is Dom Cash's
king and the paid off Home Mortgage has
taken the place of the BMW as the status
symbol of choice we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Ken Coleman
Ramsay personality is my co-host today
as we take your questions at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
can a rare thing has occurred
um
uh two times in the past six months uh I
have been in complete agreement with
Bernie Sanders
It Isn't So Dave no I mean you got it
when it is when it is what it is it is
what it is that's right right one time
was when his folks watched The Borrowed
future documentary and uh his team
reached out to us and said they wanted
to use it oh wow and uh because they're
also against the uh epic student loan
failure that's out there uh they're
probably coming to different conclusions
about the failure than we are but uh
we're at least in agreement that the
thing is a failure and they reached out
to us on that and the second time was
when I looked down at this market watch
um article that just came out where it
says the federal reserve's policy of
steep interest rate hikes is not helping
the struggling economy and is instead
hurting working Americans Senator Bernie
Sanders said I think they're hurting the
situation I think it is wrong to be
saying that the way we're going to deal
with inflation is by lowering wages and
increasing unemployment the Vermont
independent said in an interview with
NBC news's Meet the Press this is not
what we should be doing this inflation
thing is a real issue it's a global
issue and but at a time when working
families are struggling when the people
on top are doing phenomenally well I
don't think you go after the working
people
uh Sanders also said he would not raise
interest rates any higher completely
agree Senator Bernie Sanders yeah wow I
mean this is a rarity I find myself in
agreement sometimes with people that I
am seldom in agreement with but that's
okay if they say the truth they say the
truth that's right I can line up with it
um he goes on to say some other things
of course that I don't agree with but
that's okay I mean we're
um
there's no question that uh in my mind
that the FED is using an Antiquated
monetary policy that is absolutely going
to backlash on them they're they're
going to continue to screw up this
economy rather than help it they're
trying to squash inflation that was
created by things other than an
overheated economy the economy
overheating uh you know due to too much
Prosperity God forbid was not what
caused this inflation that was what
caused inflation in the 70s and this is
the monetary policy that was invoked in
the 70s that's how and up into the 80s
and that's how Jimmy Carter ran interest
rates up into the 18 fixed rate for
housing
I remember trying to sell houses in
1982. 18 fixed rates for housing that
was a mortgage rate like a credit card
it's unbelievable that's what we had and
it was this very policy this very view
of monetary policy that this is how you
correct economic inflation is you it's
kind of like chemotherapy yes you try to
kill the patient Yeah a different way
before the cancer gets them that's right
I mean if you if you know people or if
you've ever had chemotherapy I mean they
basically destroy your body in an effort
to destroy the cancer cells and it works
but this will work eventually but the
devastating side effects are going to be
very very real so yeah the FED is out to
lunch they're smoking crack they are
using a hammer uh they're they're
dropping an atom bomb on a piss ant here
and it's absolutely ridiculous they're
Overkill Overkill Overkill and they're
going to cause bigger problems the the
labor problem is not due to an economic
inflation it's due to the pandemic and
you Boze those quarantine issues out of
Washington you disrupted the supply
chain you disrupted the labor market
and it turned into an inflationary
economy and that's what did it yeah uh
all in an effort to flatten the curve
remember when we had to flatten the
curve now we got a new curve we got to
flatten and they're getting ready to
flatten everybody with it yeah and so
now we've got mortgage interest rates of
seven percent when I blinker go there
with three percent
and uh we God forbid house prices were
doing well God forbid the housing market
was too hot
you know and uh if you let these things
burn out they burn themselves out
without going ahead and walking up in
the middle of it and just screwing
around with it Sanders is exactly right
it's going to hurt working people in an
effort to look like you're doing
something well and Jerome Powell has
said that very thing he's come out and
said on multiple occasions you can look
it up uh he has said that this is the
only way to deal with this we've got to
relieve wage pressure so that's a fancy
phrase that means they think that wages
are too high hourly wages and salaries
are absolutely high but the reality is
instead of letting the market work
itself out and yes you have some spikes
in inflation when you see wages go up
that's just the natural way it works
folks when when a target's got to hire
somebody and pay him twenty dollars an
hour and they were paying him 14 or 16
or whatever we can clap and applaud I'm
glad for that I want everybody to make
more money but Target is in the business
of profit and so they're gonna then pass
the cost on to you and your loofah is
going to cost more the other factor that
has that is that has affected wage
increase is that we saw a tremendous
amount of people in the ages of 53 to
65. uh I was studying this data this
week Dave they went home they looked at
their retirement accounts and they said
we don't have to work and when the
pandemic disrupted everything and they
went home and everything kind of changed
they went and said well you know what
I've got enough and they they left the
marketplace and that has created a big
gap that we see now where companies are
trying to find people and so it's up in
the Annie I'm going to pay you a signing
bonus I'm gonna pay you 15 more to do
the same job and that's the reality on
the street that has helped push
inflation to a stubborn level that we
are now because supply chain is fixed we
don't see ships sitting off of Long
Beach anymore and and so Bernie's
writing saying that so Jerome Powell
saying we've got to drive unemployment
up he's saying those exact things we
want to see unemployment six six and a
half percent now here's the other thing
though you unemployment does not count
able-bodied people who are not looking
for work that is correct
and we've got seven million men males
seven million males between the ages of
25 and 54 that are able-bodied and are
not looking for work that's correct what
are they doing
when they're interviewed they said
screens
translation
Halo and Call of Duty yeah
uh while smoking pot in their mother's
basement
and they're 32 years old
we've got a a way too large a segment of
our male population that is completely
self-selected out of the workplace and
is creating a labor shortage yeah and
you know how are these people eating uh
let me help you with this government
support yes and some of you mamas need
to throw your babies out in the streets
so they can be Cowboys
oh unbelievable that's right that's spot
on
hey let me just tell you
an eagle that doesn't leave the nest
eventually he's known as a turkey that's
how this works so
um this is what's going on in the
economy boys and girls it's real stuff
out there we have a work ethic crisis in
America
for sure without a doubt we got people
aiming at mediocrity instead of trying
to be somebody
this is the Ramsey Show
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey guys I want to share something
exciting our team has been working on
for well over a year we've built a brand
new debit card that helps you spend and
save the Ramsay way it's called gazelle
the gazelle debit card works the same as
your standard debit card with the same
FDIC protections provided by our bank
partner password n a member FDIC with
gazelle your privacy is important we
won't sell your personal information
which means you won't have debt pushed
on you imagine not having an inbox full
of credit card offers coming at you
every week the gazelle debit card
eliminates these distractions and helps
you attack your money goals fast plus it
offers benefits others don't like no
monthly fees and a seamless connection
with every dollar and did I mention we
won't push debt on you guys your money
is your money you work hard your gazelle
intense and now your debit card is too
get the gazelle debit card and take
control of your money for good go to
ramseysolutions.com gazelle to sign up
that's
ramsesolutions.com gazelle
[Music]
Ken Coleman Ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
of the book from paycheck to purpose
how many of you are listening to the
show today wish you'd learned how to
handle money the right way when you were
in high school yeah me too think of all
the money mistakes that would have never
happened well parents even though you
can't go back in time you can make sure
your teens learn how to handle their
money now while they're in school like
how to budget how to save how to spend
wisely how to avoid debt foundations and
personal finance is the homeschool
curriculum we put together here at
Ramsey it'll give your teens the tools
they need to win with money to pay cash
for college to stay out of debt and it's
not just another homeschool curriculum
it is a life-changing course that will
completely transform how your teens
think about money so give your teens the
money skills they need now for the rest
of their lives foundations in personal
finance homeschool curriculum find out
more at ramsesolutions.com slash
homeschool Annie is with us Annie is in
Raleigh North Carolina hi Annie welcome
welcome to the Ramsay show hi y'all
thank you for taking the call sure
what's up
my uh my father-in-law's family owned a
property
the home was demolished because it had
fallen into disrepair
we thought that the property would sit
there forever because it's not in a
desirable neighborhood but then we
received a property sale agreement for
the property
saying they would pay us about five
thousand dollars for the property
after they pay all the liens escrow
taxes recording fees all of that we
thought that that sounded like a great
deal but they haven't done a title
search we don't have the money to do a
title search unless we use our emergency
fund
so we think that this is going to fall
through but we don't know if we need to
do a title search and try to resolve
this property with the other heirs
there's no money that we know of to be
made off of it because of the
liens and taxes that have are back taxes
at this point we just don't know what to
do we don't want to use our emergency
fund but we
it's not your responsibility it's not
your money it's not your responsibility
okay it's not your property
okay is it
no it is still in the grandmother's name
yeah well but I'm saying and she didn't
have a will
right it has not gone through probate
okay when did she die
2002. good Lord
okay and how many errors does she have
uh my husband would be the one on this
side and then there is a son on the
other side that is still loving
there's only two people
right because the other son is still
alive the
property owner's son is still alive on
one side and then he has all of his kids
and then my husband was the only
surviving child of
the owners oh okay
family so there's only two surviving
child
right the his his brothers and sisters
that passed a day of kids
okay all right then yeah then those are
the two errors it sounds like so both of
them ought to be able to get together
and sign a deed shouldn't they
okay but doesn't have to go through
probate to
uh ask a title company in your state I'm
not sure
okay 2002 if you can just uh both of you
sign affidavits that you're the only
heirs and you sign it
um not sure it'll be good enough for
title policy but uh but you can probably
transfer the title depending on where
your state I don't know your State's
laws that well so they are advertising
this property for sale the company that
reached out to us how are they
advertising it for sale they don't own
it
I don't know but I accidentally found it
on Zillow one day yeah well you need to
call them and tell them not to advertise
them for sale since they don't own it
okay if they want to buy and close on it
then they can split it up for sale
but we shouldn't use our emergency funds
no you should not use any money
okay
you should be just let the buyer pay the
cost to have the title searched and have
them place it with a title company and
if the title company can tell you
whether you've got to run it through
probate and if they want to run it
through probate they can pay the cost
for that it's not worth it it's not
worth anything it's not gonna put any
money in your pocket
okay
right and we are
we are living paycheck to paycheck
except for our very small do not pay any
money for a transaction here
okay the only thing you want to do is
have your husband and his his uh Uncle I
guess it is or whatever it is sign a
deed and get money that's the only thing
we want to do here there's no other
transaction there's no other calories
but let the people know they don't need
to be advertising the property unless uh
unless they want to close on it and they
need to go to the title company and the
title company can tell them whether they
need to go through probate or not okay
but you're yeah they should stop they
don't need to be advertising something
they don't own these Goobs but um it
sounds like it's more trouble than it's
worth I think I just forget about it and
move on with my life it doesn't sound
like by the time you finish all this
you're going to end up with anything
except a bunch of worry and headaches do
not write any checks
under any circumstances for this
property it is not your problem it's
someone else's problem that's simple
Virginia is with us in Orlando hi
Virginia welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi thank you so much for taking the call
sure what's up I I well I called back in
March and got through and had asked some
advice about paying down my mortgage
making a rather large fifty thousand
dollars I pay down on my mortgage
and after some discussion uh we all came
to the realization that was a good idea
so I did
and I've still been aggressively paying
on my mortgage
while putting money towards my emergency
Finance savings
and then last week I found out that my
position at work is being eliminated
so I have a couple of options
I had planned on working another seven
to ten years continuing to build up
retirement
so I can look for another position I've
got
about
40 days to do that yep or
I can take the severance package
I've been there over 35 years I can take
this everyone's Cottage and early
retirement
he loves my retirement benefits for
insurance Etc
um
and I do have a 401k through work as
well as
a small beneficiary Ira how old are you
um I'm 55. okay you can't access the
401K
um and I don't know why you can't take
retirement package Severance and go get
a job
well I can't go get a
so I think I can take the severance
package in retirement yeah
together
um I do have a pension
it's doing my employer and I think I can
access that yep
um and I ran just the estimator on it if
I took it as a single life annuity it
would be 1400 and change a month
I would take it as a lump sum and roll
it into an IRA and not take it and go
get a job
that was
or I can take the lump sum which is like
300 and change yep roll that into an IRA
and keep working
so I can take Severance and early
retirement yep and then go out and get
another job yes
yep
you weren't ready to be out to pasture
and I'm not putting you out to pasture
and this is Virginia this is known as a
win-win if you look at a shining bonus
into the next deal
well but it's going to be a highly tax
fighting bonus
because it's being paid as a lump sum
what the retirement or the severance
just Discover it well good take it
it's what signing bonuses are taxable
yeah I'd go get a job kiddo no question
what'd you do yeah this fast forward is
everything yeah everything paying off
the house faster got a big bunch of
money and
there's extra stuff extra money all darn
fire me again please
this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
Coleman Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book from
paycheck to purpose is my co-host today
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the
death free stage Monique is with us hey
Monique how are you I'm good and
yourself better than I deserve where do
you live I live in Norfolk Virginia
welcome to Nashville and here to do a
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off I paid off 76 430 in 21 months good
for you and your range of income during
that time I'm about 60 to 70. good for
you what do you do for a living I'm a
realtor and Air Force reservist oh
thanks for your service thanks for
yourself and uh what kind of uh that was
the 76 000. it was my house all right
paid for house yes sir weird yes sir I
love you awesome well done kiddo what's
the house worth the house is worth now
about two hundred and thirty thousand
wow how's that feel it feels fantastic I
mean like you got no payments I don't I
remember when I started the seven baby
steps back in 07 and I was like getting
out of debt and I never even thought
that I even wanted to own a house and
now like I own the house and no one can
take my house or my car if something
goes wrong wow
your family has to be looking at you
like wow I hope so
congratulations thank you how old are
you 41. well done well done young lady
very well done and a paid for stinking
house what's the house worth you said
about 2 30. about 2 30. all right very
good very good all right tell us the
story what happened what got you started
on all this Ramsey stuff so in 2007 my
co-worker I had just started a job at
American Airlines and she said that you
said that I shouldn't invest my money
unless I if I unless I didn't have any
debt and I thought it was crazy so I
went home I read the book that weekend
and I was like well I guess I can give
it a try for a year and 15 years later
I've made my way all the way through the
baby steps I love it yeah that's crazy
let me go read and see if this guy
really said that and you're like well no
he actually did say it I think it makes
sense you know and 15 years later here
we are yeah 41 years old and I just
stuck with it I was in the U.S Airways
American Airlines layoff and then I had
add two more layoffs within a span of
four years and I never had a financial
crisis at all wow
wow wow that really you're amazing very
very very well done how much you got in
retirement
um I have my total net worth now is
about
um four hundred thousand good for you
wow you are on your way to Baby Steps
Millionaire Next Stop I hope so we'll
soon later well done 15 years and here
we are that's exactly that's amazing and
going through layoff after layoff and
still pulling it up pulling it out well
done so what do you tell people the key
to getting out of debt is you're 41
years old with a paid for house
um I would say having the budget and
using the budget and never stopping like
no matter what if it's an unemployment
check if it's a severance check no
matter where the money comes no matter
how big or small always use a budget and
then
um just make the payments like I don't
care if it's two dollars or three
dollars like it doesn't matter every
little bit counts wow well first I got
to say I grew up in the 757 so uh you're
representing I love that Hampton Roads
Virginia awesome stuff
um I I'm curious to know uh what it was
like for you when you first started out
so you read the book and you go okay I
want to do this and you get into this
I'm curious from your journey because
you've been at it a long time yeah uh
when you hit maybe some patches of
discouragement is this thing ever going
to work out or maybe you were
intimidated I'm just curious what your
story was maybe early on and what you
did to get over that hump and get that
momentum going well generally speaking
I'm pretty driven so when I found out
the book I had just graduated from my
MBA and started working and I had moved
to a new city so I hadn't really had any
Roots anywhere
um so I didn't have to like necessarily
stop doing a lot and so what I focused
on was making sure that the money got to
the payments but then just doing like
free stuff the biggest challenges are
probably like friends who thought it was
weird and wanted me to do do things or
whatnot so I wasn't in a point where I
was like in a dire situation I was like
kind of in a good situation to start new
habits so that was like pretty easy
um the house was a little tough because
in the beginning
it wasn't as like exciting to pay it off
but then you know covid hit and I wasn't
sure what would happen with the real
estate because I was a fairly new agent
at the time and I was just like on the
four year anniversary I was like I'm
gonna pay this off by next year I didn't
make it the next year but I made it
within two wow so that was like the
slowest challenging part was the first
four years of paying the house wow yeah
because you don't feel the progress
right yeah and but covert gave you a
little urgency and kicked it in 100 I
realized that I could my basic living
expenses were only 1600 a month and I
was like I could work at Chick-fil-A and
make that so yeah so I got rid of the
the mortgage how long have you been in
the Air Force Reserves
um it's about nine years this month okay
wow well done very well done okay the
secret again to getting out of debt is
what having a budget taking it to it and
using it over and over no matter what it
is always applying every dollar no
matter what it is every dollar that
comes in no matter where it comes from
Severance or unemployment whatever it is
I heard you say that yep and then send
the payment no matter how small yep yep
keep sending that extra two dollars that
extra ten dollars that because you just
it's part of being in the Rhythm staying
on the plan staying on the plan staying
on the plan well done thank you
excellent excellent excellent job wow so
you feel great now yeah I can do
whatever I want now what's the first big
thing you're going to do now well the
first thing I did was I bought a coach
tote and I signed up for Orange Theory
nice okay I have a nice handbag yes okay
that's a good celebration right there
well done well done and now you can
continue to do anything you don't have
any payments you got lots of lots of
margin now I do lots of things you can
do so well done hey we got a live and
give bundle for you The Total Money
Makeover book and you'll be able to give
that to somebody maybe they'll read it
through like you did and maybe not and
maybe uh maybe we can break their
stubbornness too so we'll hand it off to
that I hope so and uh the baby steps
millionaires book the latest number one
bestseller because that's your next
chapter for sure and a one-year
membership to Financial Peace University
as well as part of the live and give
bundle so uh we'll get that to you in a
few minutes congratulations very well
done thank you Monique from Norfolk
Virginia 76 000 paid off house and
everything she's weird did it in 21
months making 60 to 70
000. count it down let's hear a debt
free screen three three two one I'm debt
free
[Applause]
it's how it's done boys and girls
this is how it's done
so uh Austin we got that video handy
that we were talking about earlier yeah
I think that absolutely applies here so
we're always telling you yeah that the
tortoise beats the hair yes and so she
starts this 15 years every little bit
every little bit every little bit and so
those of you watching on YouTube you're
going to be able to see the uh tortoise
uh actually beating the hair this isn't
actually a children's
or Dave Ramsey preaching about it as a
metaphor it's actually happened well
yeah it does I mean it I I suspect that
most hairs uh really can't keep their
eye on the ball and uh they get they get
you know they get sidetracked by
everything flashy can you fire it or not
not gonna make it it's coming up okay
because you just got 30 seconds
okay so of course we know the the
Aesop's Fable the tortoise and the hair
that the hair is distracted adds all
over the place he's stopping to look at
every little thing he's on Amazon Prime
he's you know he's doing everything and
the Tortoise is ugly and just keeps on
doesn't stop moving until they get there
you just keep pushing through keep
pushing through we even sell a version
of it okay there it is there it is this
is an actual race this is an actual race
between the hair you can see what
happens see we can look there it comes
out fast getting distracted comes out
fast but stops becomes enamored trying
to please the crowd wants to look around
at the people yeah tortoises my favorite
part the gal tries to get the rabbit's
attention come on buddy does it buddy
and there it is crosses the Finish Line
first once again proving the Fable to be
true hey this is how it works this is
how it works boys and girls we don't
sell microwaves around here we were in
the crockpot business this is the Ramsey
Show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
two and three consider it pure joy in my
brothers and sisters whenever you face
Trials of many kinds because you know
that the testing of your faith produces
perseverance
Chris Pratt says when life gives you
lemons make lemonade I read that on one
can of lemonade
I like to think it applies to life yeah
that's pretty good I read that on the
can of lemonade I wonder how that
happened open phones at triple eight
eight two five five two two five Paul is
with us in Des Moines hi Paul how are
you
hey I'm good Dave how are you better
than I deserve what's up in your world
um I just had a question for you
um real quick story before that is when
I was going through baby step two I had
about four or five credit cards and I
would pay one off and call it up and
close it and pay one off and call it up
and close it and they would always give
me resistance for closing the credit
cards
and uh one of the guys eventually I just
dropped her name and said the reason I'm
closing it is I'm on the Dave Ramsey
Clan and he said I know who the Steve
Ramsey is that you speak of and I know
that there's nothing I can say that will
change your mind
one way to shut them down that's great
okay so my question is
um I'm on baby step 3B
um
I put an offer in for a house to buy the
house in cash for right around like two
hundred thousand dollars and they might
I'm not they haven't accepted it it was
just today but they might come back with
like a counteroffer and was wondering
that's mostly all the uh I have but I
have a little bit of an emergency fund
and really my question is if I have like
a paid off house
what sort of emergency fund do I need if
my expenses are really low like if
they're like 800 a month it seems like
maybe 4 800 is a little bit low for an
emergency fund as a homeowner so just
yeah because you know we always say
three to six months of expenses as a
guideline
um but I you know you're doing something
very amazing there how old are you
36 and you're paying cash for a house
with 200 Grand or so
trying to yeah yeah I really wouldn't
want to get under 10 000.
because emergencies in your situation
are going to take the form uh of
something like a transmission going out
on a car or uh some kind of Crisis
happens and you need to fly across the
country to be with family or something
like that they're going to take that
kind of form uh they're not really going
to take the form of oh I've got to
support myself because I lost my job
because in that case you you know your
your Baseline is so low you can go you
know uh ubereats and survive right
sure so it's more going to be a lump sum
comes at you of some kind of heat and
air system goes out it's five grand or
something like that that's uh that
catches you off guard an emergency
obviously is an unexpected event and so
I I you know I would say a minimum in a
situation like that's going to be 10
grand what do you make a year
um roughly 60. yeah it's kind of
freelance it's kind of up and down month
by month I mean you you could cheat down
a little bit if you want to and you know
I'm going to close on the house and have
seven Grand in there or something like
that but no I'm not going to use the uh
you know three to six month of expenses
when your expenses are only 800 bucks I
think your life has more risk to it than
that in terms of covering it with an
emergency funds that logical
yeah yeah that totally makes sense that
that feels comfortable to me I just
wanted to yeah how much have you got no
savings total uh 2 15. okay so that
gives you 205 so you ain't got much
wiggle room on this negotiation then
yeah
yeah okay all right cool that'd be
interesting thanks for taking my call
yeah I mean the market has slowed down
and you're a cash buyer no contingencies
on mortgages
um you know
I just hold stance and if this doesn't
work I'd just say it I'm gonna get the
next house I'm gonna find one I can buy
for for that and uh the more the market
slows down the more you're gonna be able
to slip up on a deal maybe uh for the
first time in really three years
yeah you don't have a bunch of people
lining up anymore you know and he is
very attractive as a buyer yeah it's
pretty cool Paul very proud of you
that's a very neat place to be you know
we don't hear those stories very often
36 years old and I've saved up 200 000
to find a house and pay cash for it yeah
in Des Moines Iowa you can get a decent
house for 200 too I mean it's not a
shanty right you know Isaac is with us
Isaac's in New Jersey how are you Isaac
hey Dave how are you better than we
deserve sir how can we help
yeah so the reason I'm calling today um
my wife and I got married
um in last July
um congratulations I'm 22 years old what
was that congratulations
thank you yeah so I'm 22 years old I
make uh 65 000 a year
um I have no debt other than what we
took out we used credit cards to pay for
the wedding
um I own a house I owe 132 000 left on
my house
um and so I owe six thousand dollars
left on the One credit card my question
is
um the credit card is at 21 interest
rate so I was wondering if I should
um instead of keep paying the
credit card payment at the 21 because
every time I feel like I make a payment
and then I get an interest charge and it
keeps going in a circle I was wondering
if I should uh go to a credit union and
take out a personal loan
what does your wife make
uh she's in college so I'm cash flowing
her College
oh
okay
um the whole income so she doesn't she
doesn't work at all
uh
um but you know making probably about
five grand a year
not much work Okay no Okay uh she's
going to be uh she's in going to medical
school so I'm going to become a doctor
and how are we paying for that
uh cash flow so so actually this year
with financial aid
um because my income
um or her this this semester was paid
for
do the financially but then after that
uh you know I'm going to be cash flowing
it okay all right
um well the the good news is you only
owe six thousand dollars and uh the bad
news is you need to work your complete
tail end off for the next uh two months
three months four months and get paid a
thousand dollars a month on and be done
with it interest rates not the problem
intensity and focus is the issue and so
if you were going to keep the loan for
five years yeah we would refinance it
and get a lower interest rate but that's
not healthy for you you need to place
scissors across that card chop it up
have plastic surgery have a plasticity
and uh then step in there and take an
extra job or six live on nothing all of
you guys just roll up your sleeves and
punch that credit card in the nose and
if you pay a thousand dollars a month
it's gone in six months and then the
interest rate doesn't matter
mathematically and the reason it's
killing you is you're making little
bitty payments and you got a big old
interest but when you start putting
thousand fifteen hundred bucks a month
on it it's going to go away really fast
yeah it's absolutely the advice and
right now is the time to do it this is
all about hustle and getting any kind
every job possible and see how quick how
to challenge yourself yeah especially
part-time jobs there's a dearth of
part-time jobs that can pay very very
well 15 16 20 hours an hour I mean and
you can knock out six grand credit card
debt fast yeah and she could too yeah I
I challenge both of you he has an older
brother and go we could probably both
work several more hours and get this
thing done quickly yes fast fast fast
super fast that's the answer and then
the interest rate at that point doesn't
matter if you're going to keep the loan
five years you're not following what we
teach and yes you would go to the credit
union and get a new loan but you can't
borrow your way out of debt and we don't
want to keep a credit card loan around
like it's a pet I want to get rid of it
it's evil it's a disaster and it was a
mistake and so yeah let's get the mess
cleaned up as fast as possible and never
go back there again never again you got
to draw a line in the sand so hang on
I'm going to send you a belated wedding
gift uh it's called The Total Money
Makeover it's a book that'll show you
guys how to get started and how to
handle money how to get out of debt and
how to build wealth so you hang on I'll
send you a copy of it to say happy
wedding day a little bit late so well
done Ken good job today thank you sir
well done will and Austin and Zach and
Andrew and everybody in the booth well
done guys excellent work
hi I'm Dave Ramsey your host will be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there is ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
[Music]
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire backed catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
foreign
[Music]